TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan
for "The Developer
Show," and this
is your update on the coolest
developer news from Google
in the last week.
Chrome 69 Beta has added several
new CSS features, including
conic gradients, CSS scroll
snap and display cutouts.
Also included are updates to
Canvas, the DOM, and more.
Take a look at the post
for all the details.
You can now use Google
Cloud Services and APIs
right from JetBrains' integrated
development environment
with the Cloud Tools
for IntelliJ plugin.
It lets you discover
APIs, consume them,
and test against them
locally, all without having
to leave your IDE.
Check out the post
for screenshots
and a link to the plugin.
We recently introduced
Shielded VMs in beta,
so you can be confident
that workloads running
on Google Cloud Platform
haven't been penetrated by boot
malware or firmware root kits.
Head on over to the post
for more on the security
features they provide,
and how to get started.
The Istio open source
project recently
reached the 1.0 milestone.
Now, this is a key step toward
delivering the cloud services
platform that we discussed
at Google Cloud Next,
helping you manage your
services in a hybrid world where
some of your infrastructure runs
on VMs and some on Kubernetes.
Some services run on the
cloud and some on premises.
More about Istio and a link to
the project are on the post.
The Nvidia Tesla P4 GPU
is now available in beta
for accelerating
virtual workstations
and ML inference
on Compute Engine.
They provide a good
balance of price
to performance for remote
display applications
and real-time machine
learning inference.
More details and examples
are on the post linked
in the description below.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I am Timothy Jordan for
"The Developer Show."
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
Yeah, that's what I
used to say, is that--
one-take Timothy, with
five rehearsal takes.